in this video we are going to calculate
interesting quantities that have to do
with the short-term behavior of Markov
chains as opposed to those dealing with
long terms to the state behaviors but
first let us introduce the notion of
absorbing state as indicated in this
definition an absorbing state is a
recurrent state from which you cannot
escape once you get to it the transition
probabilities from K to K is 1 so in
some sense you get absorbed by the state
for example consider this transition
priority graph States 4 & 5 are both
absorbing States indeed when you get to
4 you stay in 4 or when you get to 5 you
stay in 5 state 1 2 & 3 are transient
States so if the Markov chain initially
started in 4 then it will stay in for
forever if it started in 5 it's gonna
stay in 5 forever but what if the Markov
chain started in either 1 2 or 3
eventually after some moving around you
will either make that transition to
state 4 and get absorbed by it all
you're going to do that transition and
get to 5 and get absorbed by the state 5
so the question is are you going to end
up in 4 or are you going to end up in 5
well we don't know for sure these
correspond to random events but can we
say anything about their probabilities
well let us try to calculate the
probability that you end up in 4 as an
example first it seems plausible that
this probability of adding in 4 will
depend on where you started if you start
in two you probably have more chances of
getting to 4 than if you start from 3
because if you start from 2 at the next
step you have immediately the chance of
getting to 4 but if you start from 3
there is some chance that you will go to
5 and never go to 4 or you will have to
go through 2 in order to get to 4 anyway
so it looks like the priority of
reaching for given you story from two
will be bigger than if you started from
three now from one it's unclear let us
be systematic then let us consider all
possible properties to add a pin for
depending on the initial state so let us
ask this question what is the
probability a of I that the chain
eventually settles in for given that it
started in I so in other words a of I is
the probability that you end up in for
given that you started in I now the
answer to that question is very easy for
some cases if you start in for the
variety that you add up in for is one
and if you start in five the priority
that you add up in four is zero there is
no way that you can go from five to four
what about the other cases well it's not
so clear let us consider for example
that you started from - what could
happen next
welcome state - let's built a tree you
can either with a priority 0.2 go to 4
or with a priority 0.8 you will go to 1
now in the first case you are done you
reach for but in the second case you
arrive in 1 and what happened next
you don't know but what you know is that
from that state either eventually you go
and get trapped in 5 or you go and
eventually get trapped in four what are
the probabilities of these events what
we don't know but one of them has been
defined before these represent the
probability of ending up in four given
that you start in one and that has been
defined here this is nothing else than
if one so the overall probability of
interest for us which is a of two using
the twelve og theorem you can enumerate
all options its with five to zero point
two you will go to four and then the
priority of going to for given that you
started in four easy for
plus 0.8 times a 1 now a of 4 is of
course 1 as we have discussed before so
we get a relation between a 2 and a of 1
now of course you can do the same thing
for the other state for example if you
start from 1 what can happen next while
you can go to 2 with a verb to 0.6 once
you're in - you are asking yourself what
is the property of reaching for well by
definition is a 2 or from 1 you go to 3
with a very to 0.4 and given that you
have done that what is the prodigy that
eventually you reach for it's a 3 if
initially you start with a 3 what can
happen next again with try to 0.3 you
will end up in state 2 and there a of 2
is the priority of interest or with a
priority 0.5 you go to state 1 and in
that case you get a of 1 and finally
with a verb which is 0.2 you get trapped
in five all right you can write it if
you want but 0.2 and you get trapped in
5 but we know that a of 5 is 0 so this
term will disappear so in the end you
get a system here after you replace a 4
by 1 and a 5 by 0 you get a system of
three linear equations with three
unknown and it is easy to solve I will
not do that you can do it yourself but
here are the results you will get a of 1
equals 18 over 28 a of 2 will be 20 over
28 and a of 3 will be 15 over 28 now I
express them so that we can compare them
easily and as a sanity check you can
verify that indeed the priority is
starting from 2 will be larger than the
priority story from 3 and turns out that
a of 1 will be in between the other two
so this probability
are consistent with our previous
intuition as an aside note that you
could have returned a system of five
linear equations with five unknown the
500 corresponding to the five states
possible in fact we had our five
equations here here was one another one
here and one two three so 3 plus 2 5 of
course this one was easy it was a 4
equals 1 and a 5 equals 0 that you can
replace in the air and get a limited or
restricted or smaller system of three
equations with three unknowns now what
if you had been interested instead in
finding the parity B of I that the chain
eventually settles in five given you
started in I how to do that well you can
repeat exactly all this calculation that
we have done but looking at five as the
state of interest but of course you
don't have to do this for any state I
given that you started in AI you will
eventually with Priority One end up in
either 4 or 5 so you have a of I plus B
of I equals 1 for all possible I so once
you have calculated a 1 a 2 a 3 a 4 and
a 5 you get B 1 B 2 B 3 B 4 and B 5 by
using this formula to sum up in general
the calculation of the probabilities to
reach a given absorbing state s starting
from any state I of a general Markov
chain with M States so let's assume that
you have M States will be the unique
solution of a system of M equations
with em unknown with the additional
conditions that a of s equals one and a
of s prime equals zero for the other
absorbing state
now going back to the following question
that we posed at the end of the review
on steady-state behavior we had this
diagram and we wanted to know which
recurrent class this chain would endure
if it started in one of these transient
States well we can now answer this
question for the purpose of this
calculation the trick is simply to think
of a recurrent class as one big
absorbing state and go through the
calculation as we're done here so think
about this class for example has been
one big state an absorbing state and now
forget about inside and calculate the
probability that you end up in this
class as the probability of reaching
this absorbing state given that you
start in one two and four and you do the
same kind of calculation